let's keep there are places you don't
normally have access to like this one it
may be hard to believe sis card test a
mutters kirat but this place is top
secret it's the track where
mercedes-benz test prototypes on
different kinds of pavement everything
is set up for Mercedes to demonstrate an
entirely new type of vehicle presented
on the glide start fenders a crowd of
journalists are here for the world
premiere and here it comes a truck and
not just any truck Mercedes says this
truck will revolutionize the
distribution of goods and cities 120
years after got leaked dimer built the
first motorized truck Mercedes has
finally produced the first big
electrically powered truck
so my den Stephon Buckner the head of
Mercedes truck division says diesel
technology has served us well for many
decades electrode technology has been
making great progress in passenger cars
Mercedes is now building on that
technology with its new truck their
expects electric motors to continue to
develop rapidly in the next few years
but what's really fueled development is
customer demand for emission-free
vehicles that make little or no noise
when they're on the road in cities
during all hours of day and night insuk
winnin on this sweet Argos enough said
the urban e truck weighs about one point
seven tons more than a conventional
diesel powered truck the batteries in
the frame give it a range of up to 200
kilometers between charges of course
Martha says there's more to an electric
truck than batteries and an electric
motor there are a lot of peripheral
technology to integrate starting with
this direct current socket that can take
on 150 kilowatts you won't find such
heavy-duty sockets on the wall right now
they're limited to 50 kilowatts but
higher capacity is surely the wave of
the future this holds the charging
electronics and this is where the
current is distributed during charging
and use and down here is a transformer
which is included because a truck has a
lot of equipment that takes only 24
volts like the radio and all the modern
onboard electronics these are the
radiator hoses and the distributor
there's also a high voltage air
compressor and a combustion engine the
auxilary units provide compressed air
here it's produced separately so that
the driver can operate the brakes adjust
levers and so forth on Savita
traditional truck technology also plays
an important role
Othman by the Montes says that in an
ordinary internal combustion truck a
retarder builds up enough resistance so
that the driver doesn't have to pump the
brakes the whole time when going
downhill
that's all with two braking resistors if
the truck has to brake when the battery
is full electric energy is diverted to
the resistors it doesn't vanish of
course it's converted to heat which can
be used to heat the vehicle in winter
the electronically powered rear axle is
pretty much the same as in Daimler's
evil hybrid bus with minor modifications
from Daimler the unbusy a moody fix yet
votación TN and the rear axle can also
be steered electrically so you need all
sorts of additional electronics to turn
a regular truck and do a neat right the
Fuzhou canter SL is much smaller but
it's already on the road in the 7.5
tonne class after successful pilot
testing and portugal a handful are now
undergoing road testing in germany the
hare mystics company is testing one of
them and they give it a thumbs up while
the initial costs are higher than for a
diesel truck its upkeep is much lower
and that's crucial in the logistics
industry
as if IKONOS a secular quran CMO of
thomas germany says he could envision
using more electric trucks as long as
they meet three criteria first enough
cargo space to carry the packages second
adequate range and last but not least
they have to make economic sense
Mercedes goal is to eventually reach the
point where all truck traffic in the
city is emission-free
the urban e truck is still a prototype
says Montes but shows what the future
might bring it will appear without
camouflage coloration at the IAA utility
vehicle show in September but it won't
be on the streets until at least 2020 so
until then we'll have to put up with
diesel trucks in our cities Indian state
along Jian